hey it's movie retrospective time and
we're tripping balls the stuff I'm
trying to figure out the lighting -
trying to figure out a good lighting
arrangement I don't know yeah this is
alright it's it's trying to workable its
soft bounce and try to control shadows
and [ __ ] yeah this office isn't that big
and it's not really a lot of places you
can put now and I'm not a lighting
specialist yeah this movies about
tripping balls tripping balls have seen
Jesus among other thing yeah yeah you
got Grover this movie I've never seen it
as a kid yeah scared of [ __ ] out of me
this guy's hallucinations does have some
very unsettling imagery yeah yeah but
I'll look at it now it's a good movie
it's kind of like the LSD version of
Close Encounters in the third of the
third time it is very tonally similarity
oh it's kind of like Close Encounters
yeah you like Close Encounters Close
Encounters is awesome movie it was like
the first big-budget sci-fi flick that I
could remember as a kid was Close
Encounters yeah it's like Close
Encounters put tripping balls it's about
yeah like a midnight movie version of
that yeah about a dude taking all these
psychedelic drugs and he's a scientist
yeah he's in a separate sensory
deprivation tank and he unlocks a
certain part of his mind that is kind of
like the poltergeist part of your mind
where your mind your altered state of
consciousness is now starting to
manipulate matter namely your own matter
yeah it's almost kind of like I mean
there it's the basis of it isn't kind of
in scientific reality but then they do
kind of go off on some a little more
fanciful thing but nothing so fanciful
that it doesn't sound sort of plausible
you know what I mean like he's pretty
much operating on the premise that if
you can access this kind of I guess like
an atavistic part of your brain or like
some kind of you know or tap into I
guess like the you know universal
consciousness maybe is what he's trying
to do kind of and you can sort of like
go back through yeah the Aeons and like
see the entire evolution of the human
race
beginning of the universal yeah this is
not really science or science fiction
it's more kind of like philosophy yeah
it's a philosophical movie there are
there is a scientist I&C setting and in
it yeah you know I mean which kind of
makes it a little bit more believable or
more credible even though some of the
scientists are kind of like the voices
of reason going man you're crazy you
can't do this so you don't know what
that drugs gonna do to you or come on
now with quantum physics and boobs you
know physics that can't be a great
character I do he's probably my favorite
character the whole his his buddy like
the other his colleague I guess yeah
that's telling him to knock it off yeah
the the basic premise is is this this
guy's a real scientist he's [ __ ] real
good-looking you know he's got away with
the women and he's totally self-absorbed
he really only cares about himself he
marries this beautiful woman but he just
kind of neglect her he didn't give a
[ __ ] he's gone off with the Indians so I
can smoke a peyote or doing whatever
taking he's all into himself you know
he's all up in his own ass and [ __ ] you
know it's funny in a way looking at it
now that that part of the story went
over my head as a kid yeah yeah I can
see how it what but as an adult now you
kind of you kind of go okay I see what
kind of guy they're talking about and
then he gets involved with all these
visions and [ __ ] basically he gets
mastery over his own body and I guess in
in certain cases the the the the the
physical universe around him because
he's making a vortexes and going off
into other dimensions people are trying
to pull him out member yeah so it's kind
of like poltergeist phenomena yeah I
mean I guess they're making the point
that like he has tapped into some part
of the brain that's pretty much like
made this kind of philosophical you know
the interior of his mind it's like kind
of externalizing is I guess what they're
like gaming for basically he goes into a
trance and goes through race memories
through his it through his uh his his
atoms and becomes one with kind of like
the Akashic records or the or the
universal on
conscious and he can regress his back
into a damn caveman on a couple what
happens he turns into a caveman
turns into a Chaka kind of becomes a
little bit like a like a werewolf story
for a bit yeah I definitely it's funny
because when we were watching it like I
saw this you know altered states came
out in 1980 and I probably saw it in the
early to mid 1980s the first time I
remember liking it but I think like you
said I was fairly young so I think like
a lot of the really like heady like
philosophical stuff sort of like I kind
of I got the gist of it yeah but you
know you really it's it's very dialogue
heavy you you know so you kind of have
to listen to what they're talking about
like to kind of get all this stuff and
like all the symbolism and stuff but um
so I saw it once back then I remember
liking it but then I didn't see it again
for many years and it's like when um you
know our main man Rob sent us a copy of
it which I was very excited about
because I hadn't seen it in ages
right and it bring back good memories
and it seems like one that a lot of
people don't really talk about all that
much anymore even though I think when I
was growing up like when I was in junior
high high school like me and you know
some of my friends that were kind into
like these weirder movies um
you know that was kind of a big one it
was like that and Videodrome and it's
like those were all the ones that we
used to rent yeah so um but I feel like
it kind of as good as it is I feel like
it's a little bit forgotten about
nowadays like you don't really hear a
lot of people talking about it and just
wouldn't be a popular theme today
because it goes against a lot of what
people want to believe today like the
basic moral basic premise of the story
is that being an intellectual makes you
an [ __ ] and you don't care about
other people and you'll get off into
yourself and become very selfish you
turn into a damn monster or a caveman
you only care about yourself but then it
kind of ends off with a he shook that
off and decided that searching for the
meaning of life is kind of useless
because life doesn't really have one
meaning the meaning of life changes a
lot it's it's it's transitory
so truth itself is transitory there is
not one truth that's a truth that's
always changing and once you accept that
you realize that in life the most
important thing is love yeah and living
life you know I mean with other people
you know which is Cana anti-intellectual
in a way yeah I get that much from it
necessarily because I mean the thing
about it everyone was scientists I don't
think they were demonizing the scientist
because his wife was a scientist as well
um but he was an extreme care but he was
an extreme case I think it I think it
was more like because I very much like
the first time like when we were
watching this again I was like wow this
is a lot like Jekyll and Hyde yeah and
it's funny because paddy Chayefsky who
wrote the screenplay he initially when
he was thinking about doing this movie
he did a three page screen treatment
which was loosely based on Jekyll and
Hyde so that's kind of what because you
kind of have the thing where he's like
dabbling with things he shouldn't
understand it's like and it almost it
doesn't really split him in two but it
kind of makes him turn into like a wild
man or like you know a wilder version of
himself and it got and it gets to a
point near the end where he can't
control it anymore because like at first
he's he has to take the drug or he has
to be in the sensory deprivation tank or
both to access these hallucinations to
access you know these visions these
transformations but then after a while
it starts happening on its own and you
can't really control it anymore
can't we and it'll happen wise outside
of tank eventually he gets to a point
where he's just a big blob a massive
damn matter with a face in it and you
could see that that the movie from
beyond is a direct omage to this I had
forgotten how similar that was and there
I did it didn't click until I saw it
yeah and then it clicked later on when
he was trying to shake off the shake off
this the the effects of this [ __ ] where
he's hitting one wall to the next wall
the next wall I remember we said that
video directly skål för and there's a
funny thing too is like later on like
after we watch the movie we watched a
couple other reviews welcome to the
basement
welcome to the basement had done this
and that exact scene they started
singing take on me was imagine it's like
a frame to frame the aha the people who
made the aha video stole that scene like
Frank shot yes shoppers obey homage they
homage that [ __ ] tried pretty boys try
to come out of the comic book to get ya
girl and in a way that's kind of what
was happening to the main character yeah
he was trying to cut snap out of that
altered state to get to get back to his
girl yeah amazing because babe well
here's the thing like he probably should
have listened to her to start with
because she was the one that told him
don't [ __ ] with it
she's like 1 don't [ __ ] with it and -
it's like why you keep it's like the
meeting in your life it's right here
it's Mia the kids it's your families
your friends you know acting all that
and he was like rejecting all that and
he's like looking for something else
like something more that's what I meant
by yeah anti-intellectual yes so
intellectually he couldn't he couldn't
connect with other people he was a dick
he was yes he was a dick he was a little
bit like and I mean the thing about it
it's like there's a really good like
love story in the middle of this where
you know this was William Hertz first
movie which i think is kind of amazing
cuz he's really good in this so him and
Blair Brown who are both scientists but
they're coming at things from like a
different she's more like an it in an
anthropology type of line where he's he
works with like people with
schizophrenia and he's like really kind
of interested in sensory deprivation in
different states of consciousness and
things like that so he's a little more
out there than she is she's very into
like studying people and like people's
cultures and things like that so you can
see how she's more grounded in the here
and now and the today and stuff and some
of the you know discussions that they
have early on is her kind of trying to
appeal to him that you know why do you
keep going off into these big long you
know things like to look for a meeting
like someplace else because there isn't
any you won't find anything it's all the
meeting is here you make your own and he
doesn't really want to hear that because
he seems very him as a character he's
very uncomfortable with emotions he's
uncomfortable around other people you
know even when him and Blair Browns
character like when they
first like hook up and everything like
that you can tell that I mean he loves
her and he cares about her but he can't
really express it he can't really
express it in any way and he's always
kind of like distracted and stuff and
she loves him anyway which in the end is
what redeems him now some people don't
like the ending they think oh it's like
super cheesy like oh love conquers all
blah-dee-blah
but um I you know yeah I can see how
that LS could you could be cheesy but
yeah one house could you end it and - I
think it works really well in this
because that was kind of the whole theme
of the movie it's also a movie of its
time trail when I when I saw it back
when it was new as a kid this is about
what 1980 1980 this came out and I guess
I was seeing it probably around 81
probably I liked on HBO yeah that's why
you see this in theatres that ending
this is a movie of its time that was a
good movie and this time yeah it was as
good as Close Encounters of the Third
Kind people today might say that kind
movies not that great it was back then
yeah I love Close Encounters I can watch
that forever even though the ending is
not a big [ __ ] you know explosion
fest yeah like that's what movies became
later on people Island people came out
of the alien craft and said what's up
and got reunited that was it
and then I really liked that ending yeah
I mean you know that's the thing about
ending a movie I don't feel like ending
a movie is really hard and I feel like a
lot of filmmakers nowadays but but you
know back then is well they're like oh
we have to like have end with a big
explosion you know I mean it's like they
have to have a big finish
it's like and I guess that's the easiest
thing to do right but if you can pull it
off like doing kind of a smaller ending
like this which I wouldn't call this a
smaller ending because like his wife
does like [ __ ] go into this [ __ ]
vortex like a molar Mountain [ __ ] not
only did he have not only was he you
know master of his own matter he was
[ __ ] pulling a hole in Dan space-time
continuum pretty much yeah yeah in the
room where he was doing his trance he
they do the effects are really cool the
effects hold up in this movie they
really do they look really really good
and I just had it on widescreen DVD and
it still look good I bet you
it looks even better on a good TV but
he's in a swirling vortex and she
actually goes through it it looks like
dry ice yeah but it looks really good
but it's lights and stuff yes call him
out of this interdimensional door that
he had created in this damn drug-induced
trance actually he got to the former he
didn't need the drugs yeah it was just
doing it like spontaneous he learned how
to do without it but yeah yeah well
that's what I mean I think he couldn't
control it anymore like I don't think he
meant for that to happen and I think
that the implication being that if she
had not pulled him out of the vortex at
the end he wouldn't have been able to
come back because he was going like way
back through the [ __ ] to the birth of
the universe and [ __ ] like that so he
was like becoming pure energy or
whatever the hell he was becoming so I
don't think if he would have been able
to come back if she hadn't reached in
there and got him and he kind of had he
came from like a Christian background or
at least he was mystified by
Christianity so all these visions and
hallucinations he would have under the
effects of these drugs all look like
something out of the Book of Revelations
and they're pretty badass I remember him
from you know they having to do with the
death of his father and his father
rejecting God on the deathbed and they
did that weird he's seen as his dad on
his deathbed and the [ __ ] Shroud of
turn falls over his face his dad pulls
it off and it hits the ground and what
happened it started Kelly caught on fire
and then he sees his dad with a dam with
a Rams Head with seven eyes and seven
horns crucified going off out into the
with fired flames and eventually he sees
hell some really cool effects and
sometimes watering the lamb over the
book to open the [ __ ] seven seals and
huh that was some bizarre [ __ ] to hear
but I remember it that the scenes are so
effective and they're so well done with
with the sound and everything that I
remember him since I was a kid now a
director dropped a lot of acid to see
what we're like so he could put a
hallucination on film and haven't
partaking myself yeah that's that's
about what they're pretty accurate no
heavy trip is like I can my banana he
goes and takes ayahuasca they don't call
it ayahuasca but I guess that's what he
took what the Indians down but when I
looked up on some like
different things about this movie some
of them said it was Amanita muscaria
which is like that poisonous mushroom
okay yeah Sheldon is a mushroom that's
what I think about the ritual and
everything and talking about tapping
into a cosmic consciousness it sounds
kind of like Joe Rogan talking about
ayahuasca
yeah and that does seem to be like in
that part of the world it does yeah
talking to alien Souls and stuff
yeah but it's like I really really like
I mean okay so as I said this was
actually written by Paddy Chayefsky who
this was based on his only novel that he
ever wrote he's actually more famous as
a screenwriter he wrote some Oscar
winners Marty Network some other ones so
he actually wrote this as a novel after
he had had an idea to do something about
like Jekyll and Hyde type of thing but
also like based in a scientific
framework like with all scientists as
characters so this movie it's funny to
me because I'm surprised it turned out
as good as it turned out because like
with a lot of these movies that had a
very very troubled production history
yeah it could have been a real piece of
[ __ ] oh boy yeah so initially it had a
different director it had a lower budget
and then it's like so paddy Chayefsky I
guess he had a thing because he was a
very successful screenwriter I guess he
had a thing in his contract where you
weren't really allowed to change his
script which he's maybe one of the few
people back then they could get away
with that [ __ ] so him in the first
director got into you know got into it
like when the movie was only less than
halfway done so eventually they brought
in Ken Russell now if anybody knows
anything about Ken Russell this was
actually I don't think this was the
first Ken Russell movie that I saw that
might have been layer the white worm or
maybe the devil's which are both very
very weird and I would also recommend
them I also saw a woman in love that was
perfect that layer of the white worm I
saw it was weird about remember that's a
weird it's based on a Bram Stoker story
actually but yeah so the thing the thing
about it though is that they finally end
up asking Ken Russell to direct it it's
like they were kind of you know under
the gun the budget had been going
I think initially they got 9 million
initially in it and then in the end it
ended up costing like 15 million 4
million of that was for the special
effects which like I said are still
actually very good so Ken Russell was
like well I think they asked me because
I have like a really visual imagination
and stuff but it turns out at least
according to Ken Russell's agent that he
was actually the 27th director of like
they were just going down ask him you
know like Steven Spielberg they were
asking like other directors they were
doing those like nama thank you it's
funny cuz this feels so much like an
early Spielberg flick it does a bit it
just does I'm up
okay I'm gonna almost say but I'm gonna
save my comment to the end you are I'm
gonna save it to the end are you gonna
are you gonna remember what it is I know
exactly what it is okay where I place
this movie alright so so yes so the
problem being so Ken Russell comes on at
that point it pretty much like all bad
cast and stuff like that so him and
Paddy Chayefsky then they kind of got
into it because like I said paddy
Chayefsky was very kind of thing just
like hey please don't you don't like
change my screenplay
and so what Ken Russell was trying to do
he's like I'm trying to like translate
these crazy visions that he has written
down and I'm trying to translate them
into an interesting you know way but
it's like you know Patty's not released
they're not really seeing eye to eye on
it I guess and he's like it he wouldn't
let me change any of his dialogue and
all this other kind of stuff so they
kind of fought and eventually I think
paddy Chayefsky ended up taking his name
off the movie and putting screenwriting
like under some other name like Sydney
Aaron or something which i think is
actually his real name so he didn't
really want his name on it although it
still does say in the credits because I
noticed based on the novel by but but I
don't think he has the screenwriting
credit although he did write the scream
screenplay but he was like upset about
it so this movie came out and it got
kind of you know mixed to positive
reviews it made more than its budget
back but it didn't make as much as they
were expecting I think like I said the
budget was about 15 million I think and
only end up making a little bit less
than 20 million so not a great amount of
money it but I think over the years like
at least in the 80s and into the early
90s at least what I remember
like I said I was really into you know I
had a group of friends that were into
like all these kind of weird like
midnight movies and stuff so it seemed
like one of the main ones that you know
you got to see this one cuz it's like a
[ __ ] drug trip it was a respected
movie in its era it was yeah it's kind
of a forgotten classic um time to say
that yeah forgotten classic yeah cuz I
think the last time like I said the last
time I heard people talking about it was
maybe when I was in high school like in
the late 80s early 90s maybe and I feel
like people were still talking about it
then like I said you talked about in the
same breath as like videos remember like
2001 or something like that that had
that kind of like weird it was an epic
movie yeah that weird kind of like you
know thing to it knows oh you have to
see this like all the imagery is like
super weird and it's like I was gonna
say to that a lot of the footage of Hell
like the inferno stuff that was actually
from a silent movie from the 1930s it
was based on Dante's and you look it did
look like yes they used they used a
little bit of that just yeah so to give
it that kind of like create it was it
was really updated it look it looks
creepy and it looked [ __ ] real there
is just like some great visuals in this
man it's just like I mean the the the
RAM from Revelation that's my favorite
yeah but there's also that great scene
where you know his wife is in the vision
and she's like naked and she's like
crawling on the ground and then she's
like she turns into a lizard then she
turns into a sand yeah and then like
they turn into sand and like the sand
starts blowing away like it's almost
like the Aeons are going by and yeah
it's real long like you're tripping yeah
and it's just like that and it's just
it's really really cool like creepy and
even like the regular scenes cuz I I do
have to say this is a very it's a very
philosophical movie it's a very dialogue
heavy movie and it's one that you kind
of if you want to know exactly what's
going on you do kind of have to listen
to all the nuances of conversation and
stuff because I have to say to that
[ __ ] happens like really fast like it
has action though too it's yeah it does
have action yeah yeah so it's not like
it's a dialogue heavy in the boring way
yeah yeah I didn't mean it like that I
just meant that this is one where you
really have to listen to people's
conversations I would put the mood okay
I'm gonna wrap it
what what I'm gonna say I'm not gonna
say any more about the movie I put the
movie on par right up there with Close
Encounters of the Third Kind and
poltergeist 1 yeah I would say if you
liked those two movies you'd like this
one yeah it's good and like I said it
definitely has a lost classic it has a
2001 kind of vibe to it too like a lot
of the imagery like gives me a little
bit of that type of thing especially
like when he's having the trip and it
was go through like the universe and she
was almost Exorcist one too in a weird
way in a weird way I've heard of it I've
heard it compared to that as well like a
little bit I mean you you have to think
like the the implications of it are uh
it's kind of a ballsy movie like Chris
basically what it's saying is that there
is no deeper meaning of life yeah it is
as good as all those movies that I
mentioned but I think it's like I said
for some reason it slipped through the
cracks I think it got overplayed on HBO
and it got taken for granted maybe I
forgot because I remember it was on
heavy rotation that it was I saw it a
bunch of times just like when I was
growing up I think they burned it out I
hadn't seen the movie in a long time I
hadn't seen it since I was a kid and as
an adult I appreciated appreciated the
movie a lot more you know it's really
funny I probably I mean when we watched
it for this review like you know
yesterday or the day before I remembered
I hadn't seen it for many years and I
remembered the special effects not
looking that good they look good
but then when I watched it again like
especially I was like you know when he
turns out of the chalk and like you know
what you know with the optical work and
stuff like that which always looks a
little bit weird from that time just
because of the way they did it but it's
like when I watched it again I was like
holy crabs this special effects and this
are really good and they really held up
especially like his kind of Cronenberg
Ian's like transformations he's like
where his arm and stuff is all bubbling
out I think Dick Smith might have worked
on that the film to video transfer
probably wasn't very good that's what we
were seeing we were seeing it on those
old TVs yeah maybe that's what it was
yeah it probably looks really good in
the theater and we didn't get that
effect until we see it now on DVD or
blu-ray yeah on a good HD TV you know
then you can see how cool the damn movie
looked
because the whole time I was like cuz I
remembered him going into the isolation
tank and coming out being a Chaka or
being you know an Australian or whatever
we're joking around College I'm a
culture shock that's what I call any
kind of little australopithecus kind of
creature but it's like I I had
remembered I was waiting for that to
happen and I remembered I was like oh
that was so cheesy looking I remember
but then when he came out I'm like oh
that's not cheesy looking at all he does
actually kind of look like an it you
know was it William Hurt playing it with
another actor we think cheesy about the
Chaka was he could tell that the guy
playing the Chaka was some kind of a
dancer I had dance training well he was
clearly an acrobat which is what they
wanted because they wanted somebody that
could climb and like jump around like
like an ape would the way he's doing his
head and everything you know I mean you
could he could tell you was the wild
animal he's looking like a dancer yeah
sounds and stuff when you would think
it'd be like [ __ ] primal screens or
clicks or something something monkey
yeah that's actually it's funny that you
point that out because when he was when
William Hertz character whose name is
Edward Jessup by the way yeah when he
was in the tank he sees and he said that
he was regressing and he made a noise
and it sounded like a monkey noise yeah
like a ape noise I wouldn't have had I
wouldn't have I wouldn't have had a
man's voice coming out of that I would
have dubbed in a bunch of monkey noises
bit baboons and chimps and [ __ ] like
that
yeah yeah yeah I was right it would have
been a lot more effective I think yeah
maybe like a baboon screaming yeah that
would have been alarming it had been a
lot more alarming I think now the scenes
with the chalk in it were kind of
reminded me a lot of American Werewolf
in London that's exactly what I was
gonna say because yeah he because he's
like wakes up in the zoo the funny thing
I was like well we were watching the
Walker to the basement think about that
there's one scene in this where the
Chuck is like running around and he
jumps over a wall and suddenly top ear
it's just like right there yeah you know
what I mean and I thought that was
really funny and they like cracked up
and they were like I need more lead up
to that he was actually jumping into a
zoo because yeah you weren't expecting
him to just like be in the middle of
Boston or wherever the [ __ ] he was and
he just jumps over long there's like a
big [ __ ] I thought it was a ride out
first but actually I think it was at up
here
they didn't have like a horny just had
that little yeah that's right snorted
that little snooty thing like over his
mouth but I think it's a good movie yeah
I think it's a good movie if you saw it
as a kid haven't seen it a long time
Glenn Rhee watch it you have a different
take on it if you've never seen it it's
I think it's a lost classic yeah it's as
good as Close Encounters I'd say it's
super trippy and like I said it was
based on it was actually based on some
real research they were doing back in
the 60s like with ketamine and stuff
like that and they were good at building
up tension to him messing around in that
damn tank you're like what the hell's
going on it is kind of eerie it is that
it has like a really eerie tone to like
a lot of Ken Russell's movies have that
like he's really really good at setting
up these really like unsettling looking
images and unsettling shots and stuff um
one thing I was gonna say earlier on was
that one thing that is kind of strange
about this and maybe I don't know maybe
it kind of like feeds into the whole
like disconnection between him and his
wife which is kind of one of the main
themes like at the center of the story
is that he basically meets her at a
party like very very early in the movie
and then like there's no you know
there's no like um card that says like 7
years later or anything like that it's
just suddenly the next scene at 7 years
later like they've been married for 7
years they have two kids all of a sudden
it's like you know they're talking about
getting divorced
yeah time goes feral and you're like
what so it's like in a way I guess he
meets her and like a few minutes later
is already divorcing her and they got
kids like what the hell happened yeah
well it seems like they meet and then
they have sex and then they have like
you know a couple like kind of in-depth
conversations and then they're like oh
we should get married
and then the next scene is like they've
been married for seven years yeah two
kids one of those kids is Drew Barrymore
by the way it knows she doesn't have any
lines or anything she's just like in the
background you can't really see her but
I think it may have been more than maybe
they edited it out maybe I haven't heard
much about it here's the weird thing
it's like the DVD that we got that Rob
sent us there's I don't think there's
any extras on there except for a couple
of trailers and like just some text like
kind of telling you a little bit about
the background of the movie yeah but
it's like I heard that a blu-ray release
came out but it doesn't have anything on
it either yeah so I feel like I don't
know and save anything if there's yeah I
don't know if there's not any background
footage or
nobody thinks like they don't like
people don't care enough to like make it
a long time ago they probably keep
anything there's a lot of stuff that was
lost I guess so I mean cuz nobody
thought about it back then it's like oh
you know one day they will forty year
isn't everyone all this at you shed on
it about what we're doing it's like now
they save everything but it's like it's
it's kind of sad I mean I know that
there was a book written about this like
about the making of it and stuff
but it doesn't seem like there is a
documentary I mean this needs like a
[ __ ] criterion collection or
something like that like with some
interviews with the people and yeah [ __ ]
like that I mean I would really like
that because I would really like and and
also I would really like a little bit
about the real doctors and like their
ketamine experiments and stuff like that
that this original screenplay was kind
of based on because they said that the
whole thing about the chalk and
everything they got that from like one
real thing where they were doing like a
ketamine experiment and they were
working with the sensory deprivation
tank and one of the doctors that was
doing the [ __ ] started jumping up and
down and said he was a chimpanzee and
that he was like on the savanna and like
he was a proto human and stuff like that
so they got that like right from the
right from their real research drugs are
bad but yeah seriously this is a really
good if you're like into really weird
like drug movies and like stuff with
like really trippy visuals and stuff I
don't know if I'd call this a horror
movie it does have some kind of horror
II kind of elements it's kind of sci-fi
but it's more like I said more on the
philosophical creepy weird end of sci-fi
philosophical action movie yeah it's not
like hard sci-fi or anything like that
it's kind of like hard to classify a
paranormal movie it is kind of yeah it
kind of falls into that weird gap of
like sort of scientific and sort of Nod
and stuff like that but yeah so if
you've never seen altered states and if
you're into Ken Russell seriously see
some of his other [ __ ] cuz that dude is
a [ __ ] weirdo and he makes some
really weird movies but I kind of love
them and this is easily one of his best
ones so check it out if you haven't seen
it